hi this is Chris Pratt and I'm Jennifer
Lawrence we were doing a wired
autocomplete interview oh sorry but I
almost cut that man's head off that
would've been awesome Lawrence a natural
blonde are any of we yeah I mean I yeah
I was not this blonde but you know
technically blonde do I keep going
Holden you peel it okay it's Jennifer
Lawrence good and I'm assuming that this
artery could kill somebody if they move
slowly enough is Jennifer Lawrence
Hispanic I regret to say no I am NOT is
Jennifer Lawrence I am actually fun fact
related to Jeremy Renner that really
that is true
somebody did an ancestry report on him
and turns out really third cousins or
some whoa so where's my present
it's Jennifer moving to Lincoln Nebraska
I hope not but maybe I haven't been
informed of something I am going to
Lincoln Nebraska okay Chris begin what
is Chris Pratt made of doing I'll tell
you what he's doing he's promoting a
movie called passengers critics are
saying is the greatest movie in the
history of time what is Chris Pratt
known for primarily he's known for film
called passengers the best movie in
history in the history of movies what is
Chris Pratt like in real life
imagine your worst nightmare and then
multiply it if your worst nightmare has
to do with laughing you brought it home
and you were nice to me is Chris Pratt
from Minnesota my entire family's from
Minnesota I was born in Minnesota
I'm however it's about three years old I
moved away and grew up in primarily
water this thing but I love Minnesota
and I hate Jennifer is Chris Pratt a
lefty nope I am
Jenna's what knife is Chris Pratt using
in Jurassic world thank you I'm so glad
you asked it was a custom made knife and
it was so badass and I stole it and I
have it
and it's right by my bed so if anyone
ever tries to come and harm me yeah
ketchup I'll do it how Jennifer Lawrence
became an actress I was in New York
watching street dancing and someone took
my picture and then my life exploded how
is Jennifer Lawrence was discovered well
I was watching street dancing in New
York and what happened
well someone took my picture and my
whole life exploded it's okay watch
Street dancing how to contact Jennifer
Lawrence agent well I don't want to tell
you that here's what you do you pick up
your phone you dial 911 and you say
quickly I needed to talk to Jennifer
Lawrence it's an emergency and then
whisper there's someone in my house my
agents will come in droves
yeah the Asian will show up you'll get
to meet Janet everything how to be
Jennifer Lawrence for Halloween oh well
I guess I'd start with probably a breed
and just as soon as you walk into
wherever you're going crack open a
bottle of wine don't worry about the
glass just carry the bottle people know
who you are how was Jennifer Lawrence
Vietnamese um I spoke Vietnamese in
x-men and I think it was probably
terrible I think I can probably find you
don't worry about finding that answer is
Chris Pratt dead only on the inside is
Chris Pratt in Bride Wars yes I play a
character called Fletcher is Chris Pratt
in star wars thank God what color is
Chris Pratt's eyes very yellow the
technical term is yes is Chris Pratt
related to Brad Pitt
um no is Chris Pratt the worst Chris it
should just be this is Chris Brad the
worst kind of kind of the worst is Chris
Pratt new Harrison Ford there will only
ever be one of him by him I mean Chris
Pratt all right is Jennifer Lawrence
married no is Jennifer Lawrence quitting
Hollywood I don't know if it'll be my
choice I think I'm more likely to be
fired is Jennifer Lawrence and Star Wars
no I'm not and who are you not there
just watched a movie there's easier ways
to fight the battles of history you know
what yes on my super sweet 16 no I
wasn't on the show because we weren't
rich my parents aren't awful but in my
first job no fifth my first job was an
mtv promo for my super sweet 16 so I was
acting like one of the sweet 16 girls
but I was not I think on this next one
I'd love to see the look on my dad's
face we should do it with a little bit
of wind in your hair yeah Lawrence on
Dancing with the Stars Wow I'm so
flattered um but unfortunately the
answer is no can Chris Pratt peel this
off French braid Oh oui but I call it
freedom braid when is Chris Pratt
hosting SNL well I I hosted once I would
like to host again as soon as my
schedule is it it would allow me to and
that they would invite me back I would
love to host city and it was truly a
dream come true
when did Chris Pratt it was
this sorry oh here you tear it off when
did Chris Pratt move to Washington
I moved once to Washington when I was
seven years old recently in the last
couple of years on and I bought a second
home in Washington so we're in the
process of you know moving back and
being back there more frequently than
before did Chris Pratt kill Osama bin
Laden haha I'm not at liberty to say but
yes how did Chris Pratt got famous how
did Chris break up how did Chris Pratt
famous there we go there's your answer
[Laughter]
he got famous by being acting
why does Chris Pratt like the Seahawks
because they're solid Americans who lead
by example because Russell Wilson goes
to Seattle Children's Hospital every
Tuesday and because they're a dominant
football force that puts team first 12th
man baby drop the mic ah okay can
Jennifer Lawrence cry on cue well no not
exactly
not really I can't you know I can't eat
like it's hard crying is like water
you know this she can I've seen her do
it it's super easy for her congenital
heart speaks Spanish this is trending um
I cannot speak Spanish I wish I could
Jennifer Lawrence I can eat that whole
pizza there was a headline once that
said look how much pizza Jennifer
Lawrence ate because they were standing
outside my friend's house and we have
like we were with multiple people so we
kept ordering pizzas they thought all
the pizzas were for me that was my
favorite headline Oh myself can jennifer
lawrence play the oboe yes I can
no I played the oboe in middle school
bands I can't believe you didn't tell me
that
yeah I am a snake charmer okay can I
marry Jennifer Lawrence I don't know who
you are but the answer isn't
she's thrilled about it